wo ist dein ding
namens party war super jetzt freue ich
mich aber auf den urlaub wir haben ein
ganzes haus für uns alleine
ich bin nach wegfahren mann war dein
letztes im mai aber es war kein urlaub
es war nur ein ausflug wir haben die
hochzeit von meinem onkel gefeiert cool
ja und wir haben gegessen und gesungen
und getanzt
es gab auch einen sind gestorben und wir
haben gedreht und haben spaziergänge
gemacht
es klingt schön man habt ihr gefeiert in
der nähe von hamburg
wir haben einen casino übernachtet das
war sehr schön wir hatten super wetter
und viel spaß aber der letzte richtigen
urlaub ist sehr lange hin
wir sehen uns wenn ich wiederkomme okay
okay